yeah I know welcome to this broadcast I
hope it's a broadcast and not a false
message here from my software it says
I'm online to get a message there if I'm
really online would be sweet okay the
water is the sweet but i need some to
get me through this hour yep thanks for
the message i am indeed life that's cool
so let's get some games going and I can
promise that I'm probably not in great
shape I know I played some games today
some blitz games over the board this
morning with a friend and it didn't look
good so some way for improvement down
compared to what i did earlier I
requested a five-minute game which are
not yet get but so have a pretty decent
five-minute rating at the at the moment
like 2400 something yep I want thanks
well I did don't get a game down that's
not so great no game whatsoever no I get
one against flan ooo 68 ok let's get
going 1d form yep ok let's let's see
what is going to do we cut a sloth by
transposition someone says we have a
stuttering broadcast yeah maybe
refreshing would help okay we got a Slav
here with Bishop f5 this line is tricky
black ok he is not going for 96 black
and sacrifice a pawn there with 96 he
didn't go for that so but this line is
not so bad actually it looks some
PESA for black but still it is very very
solid it's bishop 1c8 is not great but
it's not easy to break down let's see
how it unfolds in fact my queen on b3 is
not that well placed ok hmm what to see
want to do night a 5-2 c4 may be okay
this is probably a good a good good move
ok I'm going Luke see one that's a good
good thing well I get your opening
requests but all about openings or four
openings that I don't want to play like
the cheek or in defense to the Queens
gambit or the bird opening thing is that
i really don't know this I mean the bird
opening I definitely don't play but oh
maybe I will but for those kind of
slightly offbeat openings it's um it's
really something that you should know in
some way and if you don't it gets tricky
this is a nice position here I have a
nice pressure on the C file okay um yeah
Happy Easter yeah that's still applying
I've got Easter Monday okay I can try
let us think about this how to play here
um I can take I can take on d 7 97 97
Bishop h7 King takes Quincy to check for
Luke c6 but he can't play the King there
hmm that's kind of complicated this is
maybe easier
yeah I can play a for it's alright it's
a little bit like a reverse touch
probably it's easier for me to do than
the the cheek or in Queens gambit um
there's a question about the Kasparov
versus deep blue match if the human
interfered with the move Bishop if form
and that Rui um yeah I don't know I
really don't know that's this this
matches some is and always has been kind
of kind of strange and very difficult to
judge them I don't um I don't really
have a clear opinion there okay my
opponent she gave up a pawn but he's got
some kind of hope because of the
opposite colored bishops hmm be sure to
be four maybe maybe
yeah it was a huge thing that with this
computer printout and whatever I don't
know I never followed that to the end
and I always thought that this was a
strange match also with Kasparov playing
that basically lost opening line in the
in the final game okay thought this
would be quite nice now with the bishop
coming there that I can activate the
bishop in that way but not easy still to
win Queen f4 Bishop e8 hmm yeah probably
still Queen g5 threatens Queenie 7 i'm
not sure this is maybe that's actually
interesting threatening queen is seven
there and maybe bishop is 7 f-6 as well
comments on the US Championships yes a
very enjoyable tournament and nice
coverage down I think that that is some
very very nice event and also very nice
from from pure chess point of view um
they have all the supers are the
strongest players there Nakamura
westleigh so and so on h6 I miss that
milles queen age 45 ha maybe that's just
a draw him mmm Bishop e7 was a bit
rushed
yeah you should play at age six down h6
king oh no and that's it's checkmate I
think why is this not made age six was
still very tough queen age 45 I'm not
sure what happened there but here
meeting on g7 he's got a very unlucky
piece placement there Bishop only aid
and Queen 97
yeah it's been made on made on g7 em
black cannot prevent that but he could
have played h6 that would have been much
tougher ok next one a la con mi and I am
let's see what you can do there's a
question what is my favorite line in the
Greenfeld and would I say that drool
fathers mostly for attacking oriented
players mmm nah not sure that you can
really be an attacking oriented player
everybody should detective given the
chance and yeah well i think the groom
felt is a good opening for people that
enjoy concrete play yeah like where you
can calculate move by move line by line
and if you are enjoying this kind of
play it's a it's very good playing the
goon fault also if you enjoy active play
it's a good at opening because you have
to play active in the Greenfeld you
cannot play em some slowish moves i
forgot the opening him I hope Bishop h6
is a move they're checking you three not
sure about it hmm a question do I have a
recommendation for black on how to
respond to one Knight f3 or g3 that is
consistent with my upcoming nims iboga
book hmm there are some ideas yeah there
are some ideas 90th 39 f 6 is a good way
to start when g3 goes to be five that's
a pretty good line and if they go see
for you go he's six it's not so easy to
to get those kind of not transpositions
but something something comparable but
you can try yeah and this guy he wants
to kill me in one single word he wants
to kill me with Queen age five okay I
want to play actively him
ah locking this Bishop yeah there's a
request for real no pest brayer
variations because of my constant play
of them of the of the chil'ren yeah I
will play some other lines definitely um
my book yeah my book is currently at the
editors yes so they look at at the
details and this is the one of the final
steps before release so I really hope
hope hope hope like in May or something
it's out of my hands I've have submitted
my my papers already quite a while ago
and it's nothing that nothing to do more
nothing to do from my point of view
there ok interesting there he played d
fire that's not a move I expected very
much yeah Bishop c1 is this a cool move
it looks very very strange let's do that
93 earth Queen III I can play the trump
myself maybe I'm this is an opening that
I think is quite okay and probably where
the Ponte and there okay so we get a
funny position that does he get an extra
porn at the end this is kind of strange
but he does right he gets H form hmm
weird
okay maybe I can take them it's a very
strange game you have this this game the
only thing I can definitely save on
myself i was i was playing rather
quickly
um my book yes it will be on amazon I
guess yes I'm not sure about those
ereader things not really sure i know
that it will be released in some kind of
electronic format bye bye everyone the
publisher but i'm not sure what what
this means for like amazon kindle and
things like that I really don't know
yeah its difficulty in this position him
he one day six porn unfortunately ah yes
who do I get some kind of play in this
position it's got 94 coming up maybe
roped him
who me so he's allowing me to take that
it's surprising
Bishop une Bishop g5 or how do i do I go
about this same can also play rook t7
him I'll start with this check actually
start with the check just look quite
good yeah I think I have some drawing
chances here okay can take d to actually
for Bishop g5 if I can also play Bishop
g5 right now hmm interesting check check
check hmm um yes
not sure about this okay I'm going to
take um any any questions there the
Scotch is not considered super dangerous
for black really it is an alternative
that white is going for mostly because
they might out of concrete ideas in the
Rue Lopez and some kind of let's say in
the in the berlin wall or in known in
the marshall it's not that they think
that this is so great it is just that
they don't have anything in the others
it's also the reason why you see
nowadays many em many am ruined opus
games played with d3 instead of d for
those slowish slowish moves this is
mostly because not because the d3 lines
are so brilliant it's because they don't
find anything in the martial aunts and
stuff okay what am I going to do here he
still has a pretty decent position down
maybe here not not completely sure about
the best defense he is still having some
kind some initiative there I'm not sure
that looks that doesn't look easy him
white some king is super active hmm
hmm not easy and I didn't play that well
problem
I have no idea how to how to defend King
be six maybe yeah I am very tricky
yeah I have no defense what can I do
it's just not not not holding hmm don't
know
yeah rookie evade King c8 something like
that is winning not sure what he's doing
there there are many ways to win
probably okay this is a kind of last
hope but he can go route g2 yeah you can
go wrong she too
and I still try to be tough here but
ultimately it won't be won't be helping
I could have one much easier of course
Wow
yeah now I know actually maybe I have
heard wrong now but it doesn't matter
Luke a true maybe
I was sorry that was extremely bad take
technical play my white but okay he will
win on time and now even on position he
could have killed me number of times ok
so I'm losing also on time there okay
let's sit sir let's see um I I have not
seen a chess game between Moriarty and
sherlock holmes in the film's nope a my
partner in youtube jab a partner
everybody is a partner in youtube who
has some has some ads bye bye YouTube on
so this is nothing in particular nothing
special the name is OBO go set up so
what type of players to recommend them
it depends a little bit on what lines
you play down the names o is very
versatile there are some lines that are
more inclined furthermore more suitable
for a concrete player where you have to
calculate more some lines are more
strategic in nature then the light shows
name a book out more for the strategist
yeah I don't really want to give an
overview of the lines here in this show
what I have in the book I will
definitely do something on my channel
when the book is about to be released I
really don't want to give give too much
away down especially when it is not
really completely done yeah it might
happen that they have some kind of
changes that they wonder what not yeah
the the Dragon has been played of course
by nakamura in the US Championships
there is a fully playable opening of
course still complicated though very
complicated stuff so everybody who wants
to play the dragon has to be very well
they are very knowledgeable in
with their with their book lines okay to
echo f4 here it's bit a bit sharp but it
looks nice yeah Nakamura said in the
interview um that he that he felt that
it wasn't a very good position for him
but it seems that it didn't really
materialize in the game I I didn't
really couldn't really check them that
exchange stack was very standard it
happens all the time in this opening but
I don't know if it was some one of the
cases where it should work or should be
okay or whatever there's a huge range
there i think from great too nothing
much good to whatever okay so i want to
really jump into d5 i don't want to take
the e4 pawn in this position I want to
threaten e7 here that's I think more
important than grabbing upon their money
for yes ideas like discoveries but it's
heaven is quite strong and as a question
advice for first blitz tournament sorry
them yeah if you have the chance to
practice online you should do so you
should be careful with drinking your
water ah Christ it's there a book come
about to improve deep calculation that's
a good book here by by our God in them
in the Grand Master preparation series
on one calculation that is a pretty a
pretty high level book though but it's
quite good how many years have a plane
in chess club until I really hit 2000
about two years about two years
but it was a different time yeah that
was like 25 years ago um so let's see
Queen takes for Queen f7 hmm who do we
add position yeah he wants to trade I
don't question that very much but it's
the Queen well-positioned damn i don't
want to trade at a strange position I
would really like to get afore with the
Queen that would be great and I
absolutely have to keep my porn and so
94 let's play the CM Bishop g4 you might
have 95 but then Queenie for I think I'm
keeping the pawn I can give this check
though we at position I really don't
claim to understand what's going on here
maybe 94 is also good thats it's really
a strange position
the book of our calculation that I
recommended about deep calculation this
is super high level book the Grandmaster
preparation by our God but it's really
really like for 2200 guys really not not
not below that the maroc see bind
against the Philadelphia want if you
play c44 against the feed or set up
you're basically talking about the whole
Union but you won't get it on the board
much from from one year form so I'm
taking this year and I'm glad to I don't
quite see his idea to be honest this
looks really nice for me right okay so
he wants to trade queens now hmm I see
but mmm yeah it's hard to not try it
right okay let's trade that and now this
porn on is six ha how does he want to
play there I go look he won first keep
the pot for the moment one Bishop ephod
I can take age six or possibly be a
player looked xe5 excelling at
calculation is also a book by oh god but
that's a different one that's a little
bit less complicated can also be
recommended for a little bit a little
bit weaker players in rica in comparison
I'm going east seven down and asking
this night a question he has to take now
I guess if he allows me to play b5 that
would be fantastic i think would be a
complete bind and Knight a5 he has he
has 95 okay
no it's still a nice position yeah I got
that I entered already really late in
2012 only three years ago I had the 2400
waiting for a very long time but I
always failed to make this final norm
and didn't play many tournaments yeah
looking at edit now I should have played
some tournaments and got this thing
earlier but I never never got this in ok
let's go b5 yeah Nigel short set
teaching chess will rot your brain it's
a funny quote Nigel short is famous for
those for those funny quotes um yeah
there is I mean I see the point what he
what he says basically is that when you
kind of and maybe when you teach you
have to adjust of course a little bit in
your thinking to the student and
sometimes it's so it happens that when
you teach someone who's really far far
below your level you have to kind of
adjust your level to that and this can
be tricky i think in the in the long run
but I mean what your brain is a kind of
funny way to say it I think it's not
really helping the own chess my early
ICC handle meant very very slow lungs
are mean slow and German okay so I'm
getting there here and this should i win
the exchange now I think I should right
let's win the exchange okay
no he resigned yeah yeah Nigel shorts
Scarlett Johansson variation is it was
very nice yes let someone in the chest
and the chat explain that okay I
requested a new game yeah well Nigel
said there was a position there when
there was a position where white would
love to get a knight to e5 if he had
transfer a night from somewhere on the
board to e5 the dream square and what he
said was them was basically this is the
scarlett johansson plan like he would
very much would like to make love to her
but it's never going to happen and this
is also it's also applied to this plan
and no many of those plans once you
think of a little bit more about what
you wanted you realize how that's not
going to happen okay so let's get going
here this is a funny game a play a
teammate a teammate of mine and I'm
playing um in a very straightforward
fashion here okay so let's just go back
them and be satisfied with the fact that
I have traded some some piece down okay
if I cheek wow that's very that's very
boring you're taking with a porno
yeah okay that's the one of the more
boring positions but can I get something
going there night maybe come on play for
play for stupid tricks I always like to
do that it says some way to irritate him
95 maybe something like that not sure if
it's any good okay hmm I cannot go
Knight Geo unfortunately okay let's
prevent any night b5 business h4h h5 h4
maybe it's it's not really great
it's ravaged for maybe I'm trapping my
own Queen yeah 95 is a good idea let's
let's take them and now aged four maybe
I'm not getting trapped here right at
least that it's not so clear if you can
go for ice really trading everything
okay
okay so let's see I try to invade them
trying to press water out of stone it's
probably not leading to anything much
but I still continue okay mmm Group C 3
my knight doesn't have many squares yeah
that's really something i should keep in
mind a three and it's trapped okay cool
who's sorry for starting a conversation
i have the scarlett johansson variation
yeah of course it will it will happen if
you start something like that but it's a
well better to I mean there's this there
is this famous internet rule that any
kind of discussion after some kind of I
know some kind of detour will always end
up in a discussion about Adolf Hitler
the rather take scarlet in that case
even if it's kind of going away from the
chest so let's see i have the C file but
I don't really think it would will
amount to much is there any kind of
trickery that I can apply maybe f5 or is
this crap let's play this first I a
fiver I get a 50 K 94 maybe but ok
that's the only way I see that to make
this kind of kind of a little bit
interesting this position they are night
to e6 right but I can do here or the
check first I can start with the check
actually I can't start with the check
what about this i can check here again
Oh is falling apart there yeah you have
to be persistent um okay I look like a
retired hitman that's nice no I'm really
not more like a retired retired banker
um very tired yeah actually agree that
Scarlett Johansson probably would also
look great with dark hair any thought on
the recent woman world chess
championship yes I watched watched a bit
of that I actually like to watch those
tournaments i think it's it's good fun
it's very very young very they play very
hiding chess the in the woman world
championship very little drew i have not
not many drawers and no it's quite kind
of interesting to watch I all especially
like the tie breaks it's it's pure pure
driving pure drama so some it's it's
good to watch and it's interesting chest
it's not as it's obviously not as good
as like a super elite tournament but
well it's so very very interesting and
very fighting so we don't have any a
drawers or whatever happening it's just
good to watch yeah the KO format is the
knockout form of this is debatable I i
agree but it is it is spectacular to
watch I wouldn't much like to play that
but it's good to watch okay I don't get
a game there that takes quite a while
there someone someone know nefertum f
they played this plate him before the
session why did I lose their I forgot
actually I forgot my result okay get
them been only here
modern be knowing i will take with the
upon okay yeah there was some really
good games in this event the vanco
gambits by Paco Nina were very nice
deeply she played a great great great
with initiative and and Maria mosey took
one a very nice game in the brea against
Pagani now yeah there was some really
good games down okay I'll try to make
this game here work this position work
without castling I think it it looks
like it should be very nice there from
white let's see I can I can play it for
here that could be very close though or
h4 h5 is interesting okay let's start it
from I would love to get the Petrosian
clamping not sure let's do that if you
if it takes I go g5 and now I get the
clamp so King side is closed and I want
to try to win on the queenside let's see
first of all f3 knight to g3 yeah there
will be a match who you find against
them Maria music shook and later this
year if I understand correctly which I
have to say will probably not be very
thrilling but but as who you find is
really a super big favorite them but
still it's a great opportunity for for
Maria music shook this those matches
they also um well they have to prepare
very hard i will study very hard and
will probably help her chest anyway even
if she is maybe not doing so well in the
match itself the way is so let's say the
way is probably a more rewarding than
the than the actual
actual match itself okay this is
actually not so easy in this game I'm
not quite sure that I played the
queenside um offense ESO well I don't
want the night to be 52 d for definitely
not do I have to take that hmm that's
not good my position is a bit shaky I
Scott Luke t4i look before i'm sorry i
forgot about this idea now that's pretty
good here for him now i'm not very well
coordinated here i would need like two
or three more moves okay
there's a question about the bangko on
early Queen a five move down yes it
seems that this is the way to go if you
want to make the bangko if you keep one
to keep the bangko playable let's say
you have to play this early queen 85 and
no I'm not close to becoming a GM not
really lacking quite a number of rating
points and norms and everything a
separate woman chess separate woman
chess events I'm always kind of unsure
about that I never found it to be
particularly logical that this this is
existing but i think it's it's mostly i
think that the that the female players
have to decide for theirselves they they
like to have this kind of events or not
and i think many many of them like to
have those events so yeah probably why
not yeah i don't want a knight coming to
the fire but it seems like very
difficult to prevent
yeah what can I do
I have no particular opinion about the
Nakamura neruda te game absolutely
didn't watch the game I saw that
Nakamura gave an exchange and then then
he was all her now he's blundering into
this year I really wasn't bad shape down
okay i was lucky i was lucky um now i
really don't know about this game I saw
that he gave the exchange and he said
after the game we've considered it very
dubious but I don't really don't really
know um what what happened there okay
playing Kakarot oh here with black any
other questions they have I will have a
look don't get all of the questions
definitely what is the weirdest thing
that happened to me in my chest Korea
now I don't don't really recall
something off hand that is I don't
recall something of hand if I remember
something i will i will mention it yes
i'm playing on on the internet chess
club ICC that's the county of this
twitch stream yeah this guy a played the
four pawns tech in them in the Kings
Indian yeah and this is this is this is
this is all known yeah h5 I think it's
the move
ah Jesus it's like so long ago that I
ever looked at this one not sure if you
go here doesn't look right to play
passively but he obviously knows what
he's doing him yeah it's it's it's it's
a very very difficult debate about this
woman events or why women by women now
are weaker in chess at the moment very
difficult um I I really have no no one I
have no professional opinion there let's
say I don't feel qualified to to to
commend on that very much if there is
really some kind of difference between
the two sexes there that would warrant
this kind of differentiation I really I
really cannot tell I have no no
professional idea then okay I'm going to
take here this is kind of wild yeah I
really don't know I really don't know
one thing that definitely i can say and
i probably yeah this is something that
without also from my outside outside of
chess experience I very often feel that
that women have a different way to to
approach logical problems it so it
sounds very general but i think that
from my experience at ed work where we
all very often had to solve complex
problems that's very often them the the
women had two different approaches
simply I know it's a maybe a different
way of organizing your your thoughts or
so but
and I don't I really don't know it's
just something that that I feel that
there is there there's some kind of
difference but it is it is nothing that
I can could give them a really good
opinion upon ok so I'm going to snatch
this and if he takes my night down I
have rookie form which should be quite
good my king must be the safer one here
really question do I have played other
strategy games like starcraft the only
strategy game I have some yeah well that
I regularly play and still play is a
civilization civilization for I play
quite a bit not civilization 5 ok so I'm
going here right for Queen edge form
yeah there are also purely no no I
didn't say that women don't don't are
not logical or so it's just a different
different way of organizing your
thinking it's kind of different it's
just that well you know it's not meant
in a negative way just I just feel that
there's some some something is different
there but I cannot tell you what it is
ok i know that this he doesn't have a
check their this is this is not going to
end well right this is hanging but i'll
check here check here I can check on age
5 and then we'll get to with this made
check check check check on etool Kim Ji
Won rookie to check their may ok let's
do that it's probably enough
and then look at you at the end that was
my idea yeah the unit's tucking in
civilization for I understand the other
the dreaded stack of doom but yeah Elsa
5 has some other problems so let's see
what is the best move here rook e8 maybe
I can win the rock there but he has
screen g6 at the end but check him King
f1 take on f2 King takes hmm I don't see
a win could they are check them
well I don't see you in there
a my own steam yes there's little choice
there for Sephora in five yeah I don't
really know how I should defend this my
threads of rook f2 and 24 are pretty
strong okay so he defended that's
interesting he can take him hmm cool
we gave to your Tiki AIDS I can check
him there but he has look f1 them and I
don't have a check oh ok
you
don't see when threaten a group g3 now
we add
he still has rubgy to dare to defend you
how crazy is that
yeah if the time is there's a problem
also
I completely forgot about rook h2 silly
silly silly ah
yeah losing this game is kind of
embarrassing and that was probably I
probably add force checkmates that I
didn't see
what does he doing him
I don't really get this player maybe I
can I had still lost of course yeah okay
this this must have been some kind of
media ik don't believe in that his King
was so open I didn't find a win there I
really didn't find a win that's crazy I
mean I really don't i already have to
take a look there I don't believe in
that one bit here so over here this is
this is probably the position I don't
believe in that year so come on let's
that sheet there with a comp yeah of
course and I did it right actually I
played it right this is right right
right right and now rook e8 first this
is actually not so clear look f2 it's
it's winning 27 and now I of course I
just have to do this and he gives up I
of course just this one now okay that's
that that's that's what it was okay now
I was and it was a total irritating okay
so one more year we do have KFC in in
Europe I never been there it always
struck me as quite kind of a weird kind
of weird and Jung I tend to avoid those
places nowadays if possible okay um I'm
going to go for one more game here
I hope at least one more game we are KFC
is not very common in Joan and Germany
but it exists yeah takes takes a ball
that you get get some games back to
Moose rook a EA tall so wins okay i have
a new game there i think it's more
interesting let's see let's get going
efore yeah for for the final game play
something something aggressive ok so is
going to play the evening in or
Cleveland let's go further Karis with h3
that's how they play it nowadays the top
guys okay so taking it's not good it
seems let's play here yeah the Rogozin
in the Queens gambit declined if achill
with white
yeah g 5o that's an interesting way to
play trying to clamp down on the on the
dark squares and i will definitely be
trying to play fast year with f4 and
stuff what the best fast food for health
tricky it's possible but some something
vegetable base can be can be pretty fast
in in in making ready to eat let's say
ok king you 1 might be slow but I'm
accustomed to those slowish moves and I
will play a phone now definitely
so this is supposed to be okay for him
hmm ok Knight f3 I don't know if this is
a good idea trying to trade h 45 is also
possible NTS Bishop e7 of course
not sure about this Knight f3 is the
symbols let's start with that I don't
want to spend the whole day of them 9ft
seven probably
if you mean the best fast food like the
stuff that you can get in the likes of
mcdonald supply and so on you probably
won't find anything good ever oh I don't
have a good square for my night that's
good to know Wow hmm have to go to a 4
that's not a good idea that was really
great yeah allowing allowing this yeah
that happens if you play one year for
like me and have no idea about it I'm
just dead lost him with this structure
probably hmm now what a mess what a mess
yeah I yes is check on 83 but hmm
I 593 Kings c 1 333 now I don't know
ever made a major nothing to do about it
Quincy 30 might might kill me somehow I
don't see it okay that one have 94 here
still Quincy three maybe i can stop like
Quincy three it's just totally totally
bad Quincy 3e yeah he found it it's not
exactly rocket science okay if I go look
T 3 Queen a one King detours maybe still
playable I don't know
hmm yeah I don't see how I lose I
probably do but I don't see how yeah I
don't know twin a one chick looks very
normal he's losing stuff there on f6 but
well what can you do
i know i would just take a to them so
okay what is this is that a threat now
92 problem okay i'm still going to take
them night c2 I thought bishops is six
maybe but I can take that he can take
them yes yes yes yes yes Bishop c6e can
take this bloody this bloody bishop down
hmm
pawn takes Queen e7 mate but okay he
will take with the Queen
Queen takes h1 and i will take e seven
and some other game continues I probably
dead loss but it is kind of it still
it's still on this game and how do I do
this probably really take with the pawn
them quinby one maybe or be three I am
still lost them I'm still lost yeah
remove the nighttime check made it
that's not good you missed checkmate
side i believe that i absolutely believe
that
but take that i will take the given give
the check there wow that's it's
absolutely absolutely lost yeah i had a
median one I believe that their possible
I didn't see it but it's very likely
okay so check here all right and it
still continues so night there sure sure
sure where you start with this check
here King e7 I've bishop age form and
now ASB to check I want the night to d5
maybe somewhere Queen B 5 might happen
yeah but what can I do not much
that is 6m it still continues this disk
this strange game okay chick he's
unfortunately directly trading them yes
yes the Queen trade unfortunately ok so
i resided that hey yo yo oh wow and wow
so yeah we are on earth where was the
chick made in 1 i'm pretty sure there
was one that was a really bad game let
me check that i really wanted to see
that yeah well this was one of the
absolute worst opening positions now
this is kind of a good move right but
that's not it's it's really cool yeah
naija form i came he didn't do that
it's really amazing that somehow this is
continued but it's so bad that your that
you can even blunder a little bit down
yeah night gown unfortunately it's got
Queen be fine a two to trade queen
sleigh okay guys that was an up and down
session and yeah well the opens of
silliness kind of not my opening but um
I hope you enjoyed that was I was fun I
think okay well thanks for for watching
and participating in the chat that's
always very enjoyable to have order shut
down okay guys I'm back next week same
time I guess on Monday and there's also
a simultaneous display coming up I
shouldn't forget about that there is a
simultaneous display coming next
saturday the 11th yeah that's some
important if you are a member on of the
eyes you see you can challenge me there
okay guys till then now bye